so this guy comes along Martin shkreli
who you don't really know I guess you
had lunch with the guy once right yeah
they said we have another guy he just
came on board he's interesting he's
young he's a wool tank fan he loves
hip-hop would you like to meet him
we had a brief lunch he uh he he did
mention his love of hip-hop right and I
just and I mentioned to him the
importance that I think this record is
yeah you know to the legacy of hip-hop
not even 60 days later I put a strong
offering yeah you have any like
impressions of the guy I mean he's now
like many people think he's like a total
jerk and you know I mean like said he's
like the BBC I think called the most
hated man in America right the guy's
behaved in a lot of ways that have upset
a lot of people make him think he's gone
what kind of vibe did you get off the
guy when you met him uh we talked
briefly about what he come from we feel
you know about what whoo tang me he was
actually uh he was present at this we
did a thing at MoMA will be played the
twelve minutes and he was also in our
audience so you heard the twelve minutes
and he just really enjoyed the music I
didn't I didn't like I couldn't measure
if he was a guy in college couldn't get
it you know yeah so he so he buys the
record right and then you know Bloomberg
Businessweek does this story that says
that he's the buyer of it you then found
out you know about the about kind of a
little bit more about the guy right that
he had jacked up the prices on these aid
these HIV drugs and then you know
subsequent to that he ends up getting
charged with securities fraud right so
that's all this stuff that's happened
since then right and I know you put out
a statement you know saying to the
magazine saying hey you know when we
came to this agreement you know this is
all before I knew anything about all
this stuff and you know they don't
really know anything about this right
he's been quoted someplace in December
he said to about you he said you were
arrogant and he said he'd given you a
bunch of money and he said I'd quote I'd
encourage him to shut the [ __ ] up before
he goes a little too far
we'll see what happens I think he's a
smart man he definitely acts like it
doesn't stink and he invented rap this
concept of selling one album this
backfiring for him now that's what he
said about you I don't it seems a little
hostile as a little hostile but uh
could backfire from creating a piece of
art having an idea and see it grow into
fruition far as uh me being arrogant it
depends on what day you catch me baby I
could be out again right yeah but most
people that know me you know respect me
because I am down open and very
communicative let's say he ends up going
to jail for securities fraud does it
bother you that that guy has the one
copy of this record he even said the
other day he hasn't listened to it yet
he has know when he's going to listen to
that you know it's like he's kind of
taunting people I bought the one copy
I'm not even a listen to the damn thing
he believed he bought it he could do
what he want the power of art is that so
I could never discriminate if you know
if if the most greatest man in the world
was the one who wanted to possess it it
would have been his objective if my
enemy came to an auction and was like yo
I want that picture of RZA says to throw
darts at it yeah it's being auction it
so that's something that you know I can
never ever at this age of my life and
through the years I've been I can never
discriminate who appreciate art so is
there any way for that given the nature
of the contract for more of the world to
get to hear this record he has the power
to do something really cool he can if he
want to be philanthropy he can do
something that could allow more people
to hit the record if he concurs to that
there had to be something uh really good
for art and really good for the wolf
fence